يحاول الرئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان جاهدا تجاوز الكثير من
التعقيدات القانونيه التي تحيط به على
خلفيات قضايا عديده
هنا في المحكمه العليا في نجح خان ومحامه
في الحصول على حمايه قضائيه لمده اسبوع
تحول دون اعتقاله بناء على تسعه محاضره
مفتوحه ضده عندما ينتقل السبت الى العاصمه
اسلام اباد ومن المقرر ان يمثل خان هناك
امام محكمه الابتدائيه للنظر في قضيه
تتعلق باساءته التصرف في عدد من الهدايا
باهضه الثمن كان قد تلقاها من رؤساء الدول
اثناء فتره حكمه وكانت محكمه اسلام اباد
العليا قد منعت الشرطه من اعتقال خان
اثناء انتقاله من لاهور لاسلام اباد لكن
فريق الدفاع عنه اصر على ان يحصل خان على
تلك الحمايه من محكمه لاهور ايضا تفاديا
لامكانيه اعتقاله في لاهور
تعددت الاتهامات والشكاوى ضد خان منذ حجم
الثقه عن حكومته في العاشر من ابريل
الماضي
فهو يواجه 36 قضيه تنظر فيها عدد من
المحاكم الباكستانيه تلك القضايا تتنوع
بين محاوله القتل العمد وممارسه الارهاب
والتحريض على العنف وسوء استخدام السلطه
واهانه القضاء والتلاعب الضريبي
وحسب تصريحات خان للجزيره فان تلك القضايا
هي جزء من خمس وثمانين شكوى فتحت ضو وقد
رفض القضاء معظمها لانها لا ترقى لمستوى
قضيه
وطالما نفع عمران خان وانصاره تلك التهم
والشكاوى ويقولون ان حكومه شهباز شريف
الراهنه المؤلفه من عده احزاب معارضه
لحركه انصاف التي يتزعمها تسعى بشتى الطرق
للتضييق عليه والتقليل من شعبيته وبينها
تلك الدعاء والقضائيه ومنذ الاطاحه به
يمارس عمران خان ضغوطا على حكومه
شريف من خلال تكثيف التجمعات الكبرى
لمؤيديه في مختلف المواقع كما حل مجلسي
اقليم البنجاب وسط البلاد وخير البخت نخوه
الشماليه الغربي اللذين يسيطر عليهما حزبه
في اطار الضغط لاجراء انتخابات عامه مبكره